- So, your son is now four.
And I hear he corrects you
when you're speaking Spanish.
Is this true?
- Oh, yeah.
Yeah.
- He's four.
- Yeah, he's four.
- Okay.
- 'Cause his first language is Spanish.
I didn't grow up speaking Spanish.
But because we live in Mexico City,
I was just shooting in
Spain, he's super fluent.
And he corrects me all the time.
And he does it with attitude.
- He's like, disgusted-
- He's, "Oh my god, mom."
And I'm like, "What? You're four."
Easy, easy.
- I'm disappointed.
- Yeah, he's so
disappointed in my Spanish.
He is.
- It's way easier.
It's so cool that he is
learning at such a young age.
It's easier.
- Yeah.
- You know, dialect, all of
that is easier to pick up then.
So he sounds very wise for his age.
- He's super smart.
- Okay.
- He's brilliant.
- He's brilliant, if I say so myself.
- So both of our mamas were teachers.
Were you a good student?
- I was a great student.
- I feel like you have to be.
- But I felt like I had to be.
And my mom, she was like...
In the moment, she was so annoying
'cause she would go to
the school for everything.
And she would go and ask my teacher,
"Why does she get a B?
I read this, feels like an A."
"My daughter needs to be in math class
and she needs to be on this track."
And so to have a mom like that
advocate for you at school
is super life changing
and important, looking back now.
So God bless all the
teachers in the world.
So I ended up being a great
student because she made me.
- That's amazing.
- Were you a good student?
- My mom's so angry
right now at home.
(Kelly laughs)
- I was not a...
I think the only thing that
kept me in school was the arts.
Like I just...
I love learning.
I'm an avid learner.
I love reading, I love all that.
I just didn't like...
I just think, and
especially having kids now,
people like to learn differently.
Like, you know, we learn differently.
And it's very hard for me
to sit still in a desk and-
- But the fact that we still
learn that way is weird.
- I know, it's just...
It was just very hard for me
for that many hours in a day to be like,
worksheet, worksheet.
- It's hard for most kids.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Still.
And especially like,
technology has disrupted
so many industries.
Every industry, healthcare,
how we buy stuff.
I mean, everything, but yet
it hasn't quite disrupted
how we teach in the classroom.
It should have.
It should.
- Which is interesting
'cause you thought COVID
would've changed that a tiny bit
just 'cause we all were on Zoom.
But anyway, glad that's
not still happening.